good to see you professor of hearing her
congratulations thank you so much how
was this moment of truth this was an
amazing moment standing in front of your
majesty and then receiving this this
award after all these decades that I
worked at the University and then it
became it's an emotional moment of
course it was a bit shocking yeah I was
a bit in in a shock so - standing there
with all the the people there and it's
so it's like a fairy tale or being in a
movie yourself this evening it's like
man it looks like there to me it's
wonderful I know that you want
universities to be playgrounds tell me
why yes because at universities we train
young students and the boys and girls
the talented young people and we have to
confirm them with the frontiers of
science and knowledge and I think you
need a playground there to go in unknown
territory not to be guided too much
along the paths that all we already know
so please please let universities be a
playground for the youth and to be
creative and use their brains and their
creativity and their talent that will
move us forward you'd like to teach I
know that you have big science group how
do you treat your students I treat them
as as my message somebody called me
talented soccer players like real
talents so they probably are smarter
than I am and I always tell them because
you use your opportunities are you the
demanding type no not at all because I'm
critical and I'm asking questions
because that's my duty and guiding them
a little bit but I gave them a lot of
freedom because they are so talented and
I have to encourage them and make them
enthusiastic and then they will use this
University playground with all the
beauty that you can find there you know
that human knowledge
that how you were brought up I got from
my professor a lot of freedom to invent
to discover and that helped me a lot and
he encouraged me a lot oh you have a
good idea try it and you make mistakes
and failures but you learn a lot from
that and next time you will discover
something you are about to enter another
playground now this evenings banquet
please enjoy this evening and
congratulations once again thank you
very much thank you thank you